[Music]
from warner brothers studios in
hollywood it's the conan audiency awards
celebrating excellence in the sitting
and looking arts
here now is your host conan o'brien
thank you
this is incredible
all right well ladies and gentlemen for
a night this important i think i need to
dress the part bruce do you mind
jealous ladies it's that simple for us
fellas
[Music]
and here it is the coveted audiency
awards statue that you'll be receiving
look at it
beautiful
carefully crafted from play-doh and then
spray painted gold
up to 20 minutes before the start of
this show
you'll treasure it for up to an hour all
right
our first audiency award is for the best
impression of a celebrity
and the audiency goes to the person in
seat 5d for their impression of lex
luthor from smallville
[Music]
very nice
[Music]
no audience is complete without an evil
genius
the next
you can control the weather the next
audiency award for best impression of a
celebrity goes to the person in seat 16e
for their impression of hasidic rapper
mares yahoo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i bet you get that all the time
and finally
the last audience he wore for best
impression of a celebrity and the
audience he goes to the person in seat
11 f for their impression of mo from pep
boys
[Music]
you do fine work all right our next
audience he goes to the person in our
audience who doesn't realize he's dead
[Music]
so sad it's like the sixth sense
what are you watching
[Music]
the saddest thing is that he's holding a
conan doll that's also dead
oh okay
dude
you ruined our amazing special effect
we had everyone fooled
all right this next audiency goes to the
person in seat 15m it's the award for
the audience member most likely to be a
prep school coke dealer
[Music]
most award shows have beautiful models
who escort the winners off stage
our next audience he goes to the lucky
person who's won a date with our
beautiful award girl paulina
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what a weird choice
our next audience he goes to the
audience member who's only nominated
because he's black
[Music]
our next audience he goes to the
audience member who just received a 100
000 settlement because of the last joke
[Music]
what are you giving it away for
all right it's fake